my question is what was the most what is
the most important year of your life I
think I think I think the most important
year in my life was the first one
because I think Oh in business um I
would say the first one I had
unbelievable bravado going into my dad's
liquor store right
I'd I'd been working in it since I was
14 so I had a lot of experience I was a
completely [ __ ] student and my whole
claim was you know I'm a [ __ ] student
but I'm gonna be more successful than
all of you when I talk to my friends and
so like I really talked a lot of [ __ ]
like for in and so that first year I
just remember being like obsessed like
this is really fun to tell you guys
because it's basically around the same
age like I don't know if you can imagine
maybe you can depending on how you roll
like the day I ended school I drove from
Boston to New Jersey and worked in the
liquor store that night and basically
didn't stop for seven years but let's
say didn't stop in that first year like
genuinely again at this young of an age
no Jersey Shore no dating no hanging out
no wiffle ball no nothing
7:00 a.m. liquor store 11:00 p.m. leave
every day seven days a week
sleep on Sunday because it was a half a
day right like just [ __ ] pot
committed all-in and what happened was
at the end of that year the business
went from three to ten million in the
first year which is if any of you come
from a family business or it's not super
hard to understand when you don't come
from a whole whole lot that is such a
big difference that is such a wait a
minute that is such a wait a minute I
had to buy my car at a garage sale
AJ got a new Lexus what the [ __ ] you
know like like it was such a
game-changer so it was the first year
because I think I had a lot of pent-up
bravado but I'm sure I had I'm trying to
recall I'm sure I had I definitely had I
definitely had my 1% of doubt but what
if I'm just full of [ __ ] what if I
better what if I'm talking too much [ __ ]
like what's going to happen having that
first year under my belt and having such
a crazy success
it allowed I mean you know it's been on
since then right like it hasn't been
very difficult to like believe in myself
since all right how are you guys here
hi guys hearing this okay this is
probably better you might get some weird
chin action but don't look go ahead yeah
I absolutely easily with no hesitation
will tell you right now that my mom has
a bigger impact than this culture than
anybody besides me 100% the way I was
parented and and obviously the DNA that
I think I took from her um yes and very
weirdly and you know I would tell you
that I saw my dad do a lot of things I
don't believe in you know as a Soviet
business man you know it's you know I
was mad at him as a kid now I understand
it much better when you grow up and you
guys are all about the age my dad was
when he came to America so you've lived
your whole life if you go move now to a
communist country or somewhere that's
very different than America everything
that you've been taught here comes with
you in Russia it was communism which
meant everything was the black market
which meant at every business in Russia
people stole everyone every business in
the country since it was owned by the
country for people to survive everything
was done on the black market so if you
worked at a food store you stole from
the back room and then you sold that
[ __ ] on the black market and that just
how the whole country worked so my dad
really looked at his employees as his
enemies he did trust them at all and it
created a very negative culture as a 14
15 year old kid working my dad's liquor
store they hated my dad which they took
out on me I wasn't super tough it sucked
and so I saw the things I didn't want
and then I had my own natural DNA and
then I had the way I was parented so I
would say yes it is
no question the foundation hey pretty
ballsy to run a business like this
you're not very risk-averse
how do you evaluate what risks are worth
your word or do you just kind of like
jump in
I jump in with both feet once I make the
binary decision that it's worth the risk
and basically my judgment on everything
we do including this [ __ ] rent is
scary as [ __ ] you know so you know even
stuff like that basically I think about
doomsday I basically can afford if this
company goes to dead zero from 100
million revenue that we're gonna do this
year to dead zero I can afford
personally to pay off the ten-year rent
of this place so I basically make every
risk based on if everything goes
terrible does it kill me as long as the
answer's no then I'll do it if I think
it's interesting basically I take it
right to death blow but I will never bet
and a lot of people do bet on death blow
a lot of people make bets that if they
don't play out they're dead I do not do
that
that's my immigrant in me like I won't
let that happen but I go right to the
edge of that and as things get bigger
they become bigger bets so you're right
I'm super coat I'm only comfortable in
risk I'm uncomfortable in the
alternative and so right up to death and
death being in the sense out of business
like I'm very comfortable if vaynermedia
has to go back to six people I prefer
not that would feel weird and bad but
I'm comfortable I deserve it means I
[ __ ] up a lot in a row
the truth is I think I might have
fabricated that one percent of doubt as
I don't know if you heard I was like
trying to remember if that was there I I
basically deal with doubt by not doing
anything that I have doubt in and only
doing things that I have complete
confidence in I'm I'm a little bit
countercultural to this I think you
shouldn't work on your shortcomings I'm
serious
I I think you're far better off putting
all your energy in extension your
strengths then spending your time on
your shortcomings and so the reason I
feel confident is because you've never
seen me read in public because boy would
I feel like I don't even read at
Passover [ __ ] dinner I don't even
like reading my daughter now really
knows how to read and I'm like I'm not
gonna read to her anymore let's make up
stories we shot like like like I'm such
a poor reader I'm being dead serious
right now so like like I just you know
but then I can speak in front of 25,000
people like I did last week like like
cake right so like to answer a question
I think for me to give you the real
answer for me I level it up and just
eliminate things that bring doubt into
my world and just don't do them and only
spend more time doing the things that
I'm good at and like that might have
worked out for me like there may be some
hard core things like confidence in
itself that like this is a map for
everybody but that's my real answer like
I mean there's a lot of things I know I
can't do or I would have doubt in I just
don't do them and that might sound weird
but like it's just the truth I don't
know like I don't know I just don't
think there's that much time I really
don't want to use it on things that I
can't solve like we have way too many
things that are hardwired into us it's
kind of how I think about minorities and
sexism and the market like you can sit
here
there's minorities in here they're
females in here there's people that came
from bad family situations not like you
can sit here and list everything that is
bad about why you don't have is
and easy as the white boys in here the
problem is nobody gives a [ __ ] the
market doesn't care in the same way it
will reward you
it doesn't care where you came from if
you've got the best product if you're
the best at it it will reward you it's a
thing I'm most proud of here like it's
why people win here like I don't care
Ivan we even hire Patriot fans you know
so like that's something I would really
that's probably the one prejudice thing
of Boehner so so you know I think I'm
doubt that way to like like swelling on
how you wish it was
or being aspirational to this Nirvana of
a perfect world is about as big of a
waste of time as it gets
I'd matter I'd rather just look at what
it is and go --speed yeah
making sure that drone speed and how can
you buy them to us ensure that we
maintain well I mean I have no way of
really controlling that for you other
than inspiring the debate within your
head if you thought about if you never
thought about control speed and chaotic
speed before you leave this experience
with like oh that's something and you
may recognize it in the wild one day
right as far as how I think about it I
think that much like culture or
meritocracy or anything in life it
depends on the judge and jury I can
promise you that the Mendoza line
difference of what I think is controlled
in chaotic speed and what James think is
controlling chaotic speed are very
different definitions just like what you
may think is pretty or cool or relevant
is different than other people in this
thing so I think it's about
understanding yourself I'm way more
comfortable going chaotic than James's
and I think it's super in control it's
why I've had businesses that have been
successful you know I mean I love when I
bring in people like James or even the
way AJ looked at the world or other
people that I've known oh no no I'm like
no no you know understand I've done this
I do this like how do you think we got
here you know because if you go to
controlled speed we're still 49 people
doing 6 million so how do i define it
the results
that
I wouldn't take on a political Canada's
a client right now because I don't think
the maturity of this company is in the
right place to do that I think it would
be a lot of conversation and a lot of
emotion and a lot of debate in this
company if we did I just don't think
that's the right thing to do as far as
what do I think they should do I think
they should attention arbitrage just
like vaynermedia does like everything is
based on that nothing else where is the
most underpriced attention and I would
try to get that and so it comes in a lot
of different forms for example if I was
running for president United States
right now I would spend all my time in
the battleground states and I would try
to scale one on one I would literally be
in Ohio right now knocking on every door
and maybe I'd have d-roc following me
around to make the content that I need
to spend for the rest of the world but I
would be there one-on-one because that's
where I need to win got it so I think
it's I think it's doing hand to hand
dirty combat getting you know dirt under
your fingernails where it matters and
then using content collection along the
way as distribution so whatever I told
anne-marie in Dayton Ohio might have
been smart and cool or clever or
quotable take that click clip and deploy
it across the entire country got it
Abby in Dayton Ohio but be in Florida
because that's gonna be it Ruth
what do I think this company's gonna be
in 20 years Ruth I have no [ __ ] idea
you know Ruth I don't really dream about
stuff like that to be very frank with
you like I don't know if I ever thought
about you know I took over the company
really day-to-day five years ago we were
30 people and I don't know if I
I didn't think five years ago I'm like
oh and in five years we're gonna be 700
people and this and like I don't I
really just think about buying the New
York Jets professionally and then I
don't think about anything else in
between I just kind of execute and I
feel like if I execute it will work
itself out you know but I will tell you
on a more strategic level I knew that I
wanted to build the best marketing
machine in the world whether that meant
because I wanted to have it for myself
to sell stuff to if one day I do want a
political person in place I could do
that if you know I knew I I've built
this for myself like the reason I know
vaynermedia doesn't sell is because
nobody is gonna pay for me to jump off
of having this for myself is not a
number that any sane person would pay
for this company right well like why
won't I sell vaynermedia right like the
reason I won't sell is because I want it
for myself and if I sell it then I'm not
in control now if you're an old-school
wrestling fan like I am the Million
Dollar Man used to say everybody's got a
price and he's right like if if you know
if see if Viacom wants to walk in and
pay me five billion dollars for
vaynermedia right now [ __ ] selling
but like the like but I wouldn't sell
Vayner for a billion today and it's on
paper with worth 350 right so like
nobody's gonna pay what I want to give
up the dream of having it for myself and
so when I think in long term I just want
it like when I look you know what I
think about with you know it's actually
what I thought about when I walk here I
said I wonder if the CEO of vaynermedia
is sitting in this meeting today like I
think about who's gonna run this when I
decide to use it for something else
if I go and buy k-swiss sneakers because
I think I can compete with Under Armour
and Nike because we do our thing better
than anybody else that means I'm going
to be the CEO of k-swiss
who's going to be the CEO and the
management team of this company so I
think more now about who and when then
like anything else Hey
yep
where you see like
guys I figured I'd i'll start repeating
the question i realize i'm not setting
you up for success so how are we going
to differentiate in five years are we
going to do BR stuff how are we gonna be
different I think the reason will always
be special especially if I'm really
controlling it and by the way I don't
know if I'm gonna be CEO for 15 years 3
19 as long as I'm the CEO we're gonna
win because I'm really good at buying
underpriced attention right so like the
way we're gonna differentiate is the way
we differentiate today which is we just
fundamentally understand the current
state of marketing better than others
and so that's it like that's the easiest
question for me to answer because I
don't know anything other of course VR
of course they are of course the thing
that Karen in Tulsa Okla you know is
right now inventing that's going to be
important in three years yes because I
only want to break us the only job I
have every day is to wake up and put
this company out of business by us being
the ones that put ourselves out of
business versus letting somebody out
there or do it for us
got it so we'll only innovate you guys
heard all hands-on the only thing I can
promise is change you don't like change
get the [ __ ] out because this is not
going to be a good place for you because
it's the only norm and and just so you
know at scale big companies 100 people
10 million in revenue that gets hard
people don't like change you're on a
little bit of the younger side but even
your own DNA may not like change change
is what most people hate definitely
after a certain period in your life
mid-thirties hate and even 50% of this
young crew hate because it's hardwired
change is hard okay yep
question is he's in a similar spot as me
dad's got a hardware store he wants to
blow it up what what general advice so
I'm gonna give you a very interesting
answer the first thing you have to do is
get religious and mental buy-in from
your dad it doesn't matter what the
tactics are shopify Micmac you know NFC
technology multiple locations jayvees
influencer marketing none of that [ __ ]
matters if you don't have the room to do
it so let me ask you do you think you're
gonna have the room to do it great so
then then I think sure and what I mean
by that is you're here you're paying
attention I'm not going to tell you
anything that's super crazy
if you're not on econ you've got to make
that investment it's got to be shot by
it's got to be Amazon services eBay
you've got my biggest advice to you is
to build the brand hardware stores are
not differentiated like and so is it in
New York or New Jersey you know as you
know as you know like so many people go
to hardware stores you're completely
based on location it's completely
convenience based what you need to do
and this is what I did in my dad's store
I remember thinking in retail everybody
says location location location right
and I remember thinking that's the only
thing I care about braking and I think
if you have that religious mentality
that like the one thing you don't want
to be at the mercy of is the location of
the store then you start thinking about
selling to people through online then
you start thinking about becoming a
destination people want to go to why
like is your brooms and screws and
drills so much better absolutely not so
the [ __ ] are you gonna create so you
have to create that differentiation you
got it
one more time so soccer leagues brands
on the jerseys not talks the enemy's
doing it
so I think it's inevitable that all four
sports either said sports its business
the MBA is going to do this we're not
going to freak out that there's a Pepsi
logo on the Bulls Jersey we don't give a
[ __ ]
the league's will realize that the next
day they'll all do it and that's going
to be a big business for them because I
can tell you one thing I don't want our
clients to do by signage and stadiums
because it's overpriced because when I
was a kid you go to a stadium and during
stoppage of play you looked around
because you didn't have anything else to
[ __ ] do and you saw the Pepsi sign Oh
Pepsi now you grab your phone and you
don't look around and they're just
overpriced signage is [ __ ] in stadium
it's one of the most overpriced products
in the world and the brands are getting
pissed and they want you're going to
have to look at the player so I think
everybody will do it
yep hundred percent
there's nothing or remember I only trade
attention I can promise you as much as
you look at the table as much as you the
one thing you're always looking at is
the [ __ ] player yeah I think they're
gonna be pimped out head to toe with
every [ __ ] logo you know you got it
yeah sorry I'm kidding I'm kidding I
hate in school you may love it plus it's
so fun it's so easy you're gonna hook up
have fun
you mean on the side or in the classroom
at your university none
it is my 100% believe you know I think
the question is what should we learn in
our last year if it's our last year
since we know getting paid to learn or I
think you're paying them but oh you're
paying to learn yeah okay yeah man
I got to tell you like I don't the cold
the cold college business model is the
most fascinating so you know and that's
the point right you're literally paying
and I genuinely believe in marketing
there's not a school right now teaching
anything that's right they're just not
how many of you learn marketing classes
what does it look like right so like
[ __ ] me anyway I think the best thing
you should do the list to be very frank
with you bro
honestly I think you're about to start
the part of your life where you're gonna
learn where it matters on the field
right I may throw you guys for a loop on
this one I actually think you should
just enjoy the living [ __ ] out of this
last year I'm not kidding
like you know if you're a prude if
you're me well then you'd be selling
[ __ ] and starting a business on the side
anyway but if you're not like dying to
do like I wouldn't have gone to a
[ __ ] internship like so like like
like I'm like I was broken like I could
only do it my what you know like I'm
barely even when it's my dad's a liquor
store like I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards when I was 14
like I was good like so I think that my
intuition is if you even have this
internship right that the real answer is
[ __ ] don't fail I guess because maybe
your parents would be upset but then
like I don't know like and if you want
to learn I think you'll learn more the
truth is unless you start your own
business which will take a lot of time
which I'm trying to debate is that
valuable to you in your last year when
you should probably milk this ridiculous
year that you're living which many may
think is the greatest single year of
your life right other than that you're
going to learn more in the first hundred
days of your job coming out
then they're so like to me it's just
it's a bet to like betting on strengths
and weaknesses though the value exchange
here feels like [ __ ] it just you know
yeah here into that sounds a good strap
first to make sure that you always
deploy a lot of humility because nobody
wants a because you might be wrong and
if you're wrong you're [ __ ] because if
you're the intern that's said to my face
this is garbage and you're wrong that's
bad now if you're right it's phenomenal
so I even if you really closely pay
attention to my public content I'm
really good at giving you honey before I
give you vinegar so my answer is to
hedge it like hey Mark Mark Evans I
think you're you're the best and I
really don't know i weirdly for some
reason feel compelled to tell you your
idea [ __ ] right I think you have to
hedge it because you have to be you have
to really be sure you're right plus the
other thing my man that you really need
to pay attention today bit is is it
subjective so like one of the biggest
problems is you may have something
that's an opinion and then you're
telling somebody above you that they're
wrong there's no way to prove if it's
wrong or right and they're just going to
impose their seniority on you and it's
gonna suck [ __ ] that's why the battles I
fight are proven you can prove them out
you know I also think you should go home
and try to figure out why that matters
so much here because I think it's
actually a very interesting question
that has both good and bad in it and you
should break it down we need to jam on
that
[Music]
I did it did really well yes I'm a big
believer net
yep frustrated yeah okay yeah gap go
[ __ ] yourself right
[Music]
Molly what do you want to do when you
grow do you know yet it's okay if you
don't I'm just curious to you so to me
like if you like when when I hear that
somebody wants to be the next Puff Daddy
or the next me or the next whatever
anybody wants to be whatever whatever
you want to be whatever level right I
genuinely believe that you should spend
all your time to try to go get an
internship to be as close to that person
if anybody here actually wanted to be
the next me I think that they should
have tried to be the intern on my team
versus an internet Baner media I believe
that I genuinely the closer you can get
to the Sun of what you want to be the
more likely you'll learn by relentless
[ __ ] pursuit especially I mean that
it's just the audacity to find the right
balance it's really actually interesting
it's not super different than David's
question in some ways how do you find
the right cadence and balance to be
aggressive without being [ __ ]
annoying there's people that try to
reach me every day lots of them some of
them immediately through their first
three attempts go into I will never
[ __ ] interact with this person ever
because it's coming from a bad place
like I get to be the judge in the jury
of that's what it tastes like and other
people win and eventually get there are
bats there's Pete there's a kid I meant
today for five minutes like some of
these people tried for 15 times to get
like it to me it's like if you want it
so bad first of all there may be 34
people that look like you want to be
right so you know there may be 11
hip hop business mogul people and you
can go right down the line and try to
hit up you know Birdman and P Diddy you
know 50 times each right so I think it's
worth it ma honestly like I think it's
worth it
you understand the upsides greater than
a downside like to me
how do you make yourself stand out you
need to understand that person so you
[ __ ] really try to figure out who
they are at one of the things I would do
is follow them heavily on social and
figure out what like there's a lot of
ways to break through like for example
everybody thinks the best way to get a
hold of me is to write in the email
subject I'm I've got I'm gonna help you
buy the New York Jets I've got an idea
that's going to help you buy the Jets
I'm gonna help you buy the Jets the
problem is that's what everybody does
which means that none of them get the
rail the answer is I don't know because
everybody's got a different unlock
here's what I do know about Ron Howard
and all these different fancy people I
know all of them have been penetrated
all of them because winners want to give
other winners at-bats we feel guilt and
we have to pay back to the thing that
put us there and they all do it and so
to me I think you know it's [ __ ] cool
to try to like pull that off and I
actually think it's just especially when
I think about it from a college still in
college internship level I think it's
like a fun journey actually think it's a
cool content series to start in
September and spend all of September
through like March trying to become an
intern on Team XYZ I think it's kind of
cool so yeah and you know what's funny
it's actually got similarities to my
advice in that video which is I think
the KPI for you guys being here is there
yep I mean especially Vayner
especially if you're considering to be
in this industry there are hundred
people in here 50 which are going to be
very unbelievably senior here one day
and fifty that are going to run [ __ ] out
there like that was worth the hello like
I love that you run in little packs with
each other and that's great but you can
run with packs of each other in [ __ ]
October
[Music]
and this is the easiest place to
randomly say hello
your friends and homies have much tub
for jobs to penetrate that where they're
at so I just think it's people make them
it's all people it's all [ __ ] people
80% of you got here because of people
you had some rabbi that got you into
this [ __ ] place it's gotten so hard
for us wrap the you know to your point
our biggest problem right now is
everybody wants their child or best
friend's child to be an intern here now
like next year is a disaster I'm not
like [ __ ] 100 where you see another
floor that's my only I got it okay I
need a seat for everyone in Italy on it
yes Murr technology is moving fast
Oh privacy is being invaded cuz you're
allowing it to be invaded you're giving
a privacy every [ __ ] day for
convenience and time they're not
invading you're giving it up you know
you're being watched right now you don't
give a [ __ ] I know
here's what I think happens you guys
know who led biases Len Bias was one of
the best basketball players of all time
in college and unfortunately two days
after he was drafted third overall in
the NBA he died from a drug overdose he
had he overdosed on cocaine
he's from the University of Maryland
Nancy Reagan was super anti drugs very
conservative president on that issue and
the gun and the gun and the it's funny
where I'm going with this you can see
where my head's going my punch line is
the drug laws changed here forever
here's my thing on privacy we don't give
a [ __ ] because the punch line of society
is people are unbelievable as much as
the mainstream media wants to tell you
about the one person who who has
emotional issues that will shoot 25
people in a club and it's the worst it's
the worst you know what do me a favor if
you're curious about this you know that
CNN did a series called the 60s and the
70s I don't know if this hit your radar
probably not but they did there was
eight series if you have Netflix go to
it go watch the one on terrorism in the
70s there were more terrorist acts
domestically in the 70s in this country
by 10x than what's going on now it's
unbelievable actually so what what
people will realize is we paint the
wrong pictures the reason none of us
care about privacy is because people are
good we're not doing that much bad with
the privacy what are you sad that
Toyota's following you around the
internet and putting banner ads in front
of you right like we don't do that many
bad things with it and so I think we
give a privacy now here's the punchline
I believe that somebody like Beyonce or
Rihanna is going to get killed because
of a social media post of where she is
somebody with the wrong mindset and that
everything changes that next day because
we can kill 52 children in a school and
not react but when somebody kills one of
our top ten celebrities because of this
everything will change
it's just who America is so
unfortunately what I'm trying to figure
out is what happens to privacy post the
assassination of a celebrity on the back
of it no privacy
I got deep yeah you like that one right
that's why they're paying me the big
bucks tauriel it's not this is the [ __ ]
that I think about Gina Gina I mean not
everybody's gonna even be able to ask
their question and you've jumped in with
a two-part question yep that's not a
rumor that's true yes yes great yes you
do
well I'm spot I think we already gave
you a chance aren't you sitting in front
of us so let me say this Gina listen
here's the good news our ratio of people
that have been interns that even as long
as they were not the worst thing we've
ever seen and super inappropriate our
conversion rate on the interns that have
wanted to work here is staggering I
promise you that you have a unbelievable
advantage over anybody else that wants
your spot in may 2017 now when I dig
under the hood I may found out that you
are the single worst person that's ever
come through this organization and that
would eliminate that statement but my
gut tells me that's probably not the
case yep
and you know the whole notion that
people work their way up love
meritocracy everybody like like
everybody see you they think they love
me but they I'm the best photo assistant
how do I like break that notion in their
head but I wore that series gear get it
into their heads because the more is
always the longer hours I say I'm just
like an even better prognosis so how do
I make them like real life
that's the DNA of this cut that to me is
like the easiest meth that's almost as I
said the other thing was easy like this
is easy that's what we do every day I
mean like the good news is unlike when I
promised these guys that they didn't
know I don't know go talk to every
[ __ ] person that works here they've
got the same [ __ ] story you do
because it happens every day
cool just good man I'm not the biggest
fan of modern day education under the
context of the following anybody who
takes on debt to learn entrepreneurship
or marketing in today's college
environment is getting [ __ ] yep you
need to find the places where a formal
education isn't the prerequisite to
success Justin if you don't have it
wasn't in my best interest to go try to
get a job at Goldman Sachs they weren't
looking for me so I went to the place
that I could which is my dad's liquor
store where the market was going to
decide who I was not to put the molly's
thing right like if you're a hustler go
talk to other hustlers they know what it
looks like
Harvard Stan is not going to love it as
much you know so don't don't sell to the
unsellable this is back to minorities
women things of that nature
find a places where it's sellable don't
try to impose your will like don't go
try to prove to someplace where you know
they give a [ __ ] about what school you
went to that you've got it and they
don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna find the
kid that's got it and has the [ __ ]
degree that they give a [ __ ] about find
the guy who disrespects the degree and
work there what you're lucky bro because
I didn't grow up in the environment you
did do you know how much of a hero I
would have been for making three four
thousand dollars a weekend as a kid and
I was looked at as a loser
I was making three
thousand dollars a weekend but because I
got a D and [ __ ] English I was a loser
I wish I was growing up in this
generation I'd be in [ __ ] magazines
and like heralded as the next this and
that but I think if you're you're so
lucky we've never lived in a world where
a formal education has mattered less
that's just the truth like I lived 20
years ago where anybody here who had a
who's going to a fancier school than me
look down on me now people are smarter
to be like they still may look down and
I don't think they're wrong it's just
enough people know there's a lot of
alternatives brewing and shit's gotten
weird just the way it is Kenz yeah so
the question is with social media how do
people perceive others differently now
because of it and how do they perceive
themselves I believe that all of you are
the PR agent of yourself I believe that
you guys go to places and concerts and
events just to take the photo to deploy
so that you can message to everybody who
you are I think it's [ __ ] cool some
people think it's sad or whatever I
think it's always happened it's what we
do you're wearing the clothes you're
wearing right now to tell us who you are
that's what we do we express ourselves
it's just what we do and I think we now
all have scale of media to do it now
when you ask the second part of the
question it gets really interesting
because I do think that for example
young teenage girls some of you might
have gone through this a socials in a
little bit of a different place than
some of you one of the most interesting
things I find is that I think for the
people in the analytics world here I
think that there's a lot of 13 year old
teenage girls that understand analytics
better than people that work here
because just literally putting up
content looking at how quickly it's like
understanding where it's going to end up
with how many likes pulling it down
because he didn't like the engagement or
they kind of like that whole game is
fascinating to me and and I do believe
that people some people that lack
self-esteem are wrapping their
self-esteem up into their engagement
their likes their followers and you know
that has its dangers just like anything
else has always had their danger so I
think it's an interesting time but I
think I think you subconsciously don't
even realize that you're peeing yourself
at scale so I love live events and live
divisions because I think like it's
unbelievable how much I don't think
people realize the rise of music
festivals has a lot more to do with
social media than anything else
what's been my biggest challenge how do
I overcome them I think the biggest
challenge I've had is I would say that
you know the transition from the thought
of leaving my family business was really
tough right I don't want to let my dad
down
you know AJ was coming I knew he wanted
to do something with me and I knew that
he didn't want to do it with my dad so
it was just a lot of that was really a
tough period for me um you know I'll be
very honest with you like it's no
different than the one percent doubt
like I'm sure you guys get this sense I
struggle with holding on to negativity I
actually think our culture is good
because I'm uncomfortable and negativity
and like that's why nobody's able to
really roll with it more than anything
because nobody's better than me like
nobody's gonna drive bigger business
results for this company than me and
thus if they're bringing negativity
they'll bring me down enough to not let
me do my thing
and so it's so funny I hate your
question not only because I want to give
you a good answer and like I'm gonna
[ __ ] it like I don't know like the
the realist answer is I haven't dealt
with my toughest thing yet because I
haven't dealt with the death of one of
my inner seven people right that will be
my hardest when one of my parents my
wife my children my siblings or their
spouses if God forbid one of them were
to die that's my biggest challenge other
than that like I got real [ __ ] lucky
I just think it's all easy I really do
because I don't here's why because if
you told me right now Vayner could be
40,000 people and eight billion in
revenue but I have to lose two of the
people that I just mentioned in the next
five years or it will never get bigger
than this
and I get to hold on to those eight
people for the next thirty years
guaranteed right it's just not even a
conversation so that's cool
I just know what I'm wired in which is
as hard core business as I am an
entrepreneur and I want to buy the Jets
and all that it just doesn't mean that
much to me in the scheme of things you
got it
please oh I'm sorry Dyke we got yours
too let's do it
d-roc knows this answer Oh God is HR
around oh so this is the real answer cuz
I don't want I want to stay consistent I
literally would have said to hook up
more because because you because you
heard like like I really went all into
my business like I literally like like
cute girls we're like let's go out and
I'm like no no I have to go to the
baseball card store like like real weird
crazy [ __ ]
in hindsight so that's the real answer I
don't know if that maps for you guys
that's the real answer uh you know I
think I think here's what I will say
here's something that will bring you
guys value if you knew that I'm sitting
here as a 40 year old twice your age and
I know not only like that I truly
genuinely feel that you like I'm
laughing right now inside because I
literally think that we're friends and
homies in the same age and I really mean
it
like when I play basketball those guys I
just wanted my guy like we're the same
right like I genuinely think you and I
are the same but I also know that when I
was 20 and I saw 40 year old dude I was
like that dude's so [ __ ] old like
it's so crazy how old I know like you're
thinking I am and how insanely deeply I
feel like we're aren't we the same
Austin like like I genuinely believe
we're the same and here's why I'm
telling you that if somebody told me
that if I'm able to break through to one
of you that truth you'll be much more
patient and you'll think about [ __ ]
differently if I told you you're gonna
feel exactly the same on fire hungry
change the world do your thing make your
mark all that stuff in 20 years exactly
the same maybe more but exactly the same
I think it would change you I wish you
could know that to be as true as I know
it to be so I think I would tell my 20
year old self like and it goes back to
like hook up words like look you've got
plenty of [ __ ] time to do it all
and like yeah it's gonna take a lot of
hard work to do the insanity you want
but that's what I would tell myself like
that you will not believe how young you
will feel at 40 like what's that cool
[Music]
what do I buy on the back end what I
have on the back end
show me go ahead yeah I got I got
so I think Twitter is the cocktail party
of the internet because it's the one
place we can all go when something
happens everything else we just push out
content even you know even people with
small followings stunningly don't read
every comment when they push something
out things of that nature I'm not sure
where it's going I think the thing
that's really you know the truth is I
get a lot of credit for like predicting
[ __ ] I don't predict things I just react
quickly you know like I'm just spending
a lot more time figuring out musically
than you guys that's all so I'm not sure
really don't know I do know that VR will
be the thing that trumps
the Internet itself like that you guys
are young enough to live in a VR
platform world versus an internet
platform world and that's crazy the fact
that all of you will be walking around
with contact lenses and seeing random
other [ __ ] right now
[ __ ] like you know there's real [ __ ] you
know you're too young to know what I
know which is when I was sitting in here
and I would raise my hand if I was
remember like I'm gonna launch a website
for my dad's liquor store everybody will
laughed at me and thought it was the
stupidest [ __ ] they've ever heard like I
don't think you guys realize that you're
a young 40 year old self you just might
be sitting on a beach in San Diego
full-time and living your life through
that like shit's gonna get crazy like I
actually think you guys might be young
enough to actually become robots one day
I know that that time which is why I'm
laughing I know that I genuinely think
some of you may live to 200 years old
I'm so pissed I'm not you I think I just
miss it I'm gonna be so pissed I'm gonna
be so pissed if that's what ends up
happening I feel like there's gonna be
this weird thing that happens where like
there'll be some technology changes
we're like okay anybody who's super
healthy and 35 and under they'll gonna
actually live to 250 but everybody else
and above is actually just gonna live it
normal and I'm gonna be pissed right I
really want to live what happened
so I don't know but here's what I can
promise you and it's super not different
than how we're going to differentiate
and stay ahead is I don't know but I
promise you I'll react to it real
[ __ ] fast
what am I looking forward to in any
Olympics
it is unbelievable to me how little I
give a [ __ ] about the Olympics I'm it's
Maddy it's so crazy like I don't give a
[ __ ] they've they've somehow been able
to create a scenario where it has become
the most irrelevant thing to me in my
life and I don't know and I'm like born
in Russia so like the Olympics were
super cool for me as a kid because of
Russia versus America when I was a kid
like [ __ ] I was like oh who do I read
for why am i weirdly rooting for Russia
in my spy like you know he's like you
know like like I've like so weird but
but um I'm so not much for it to be over
and then as far as was the first part of
question what drives think I think I'm
an underdog like I think ultimately my
story is going to be pretty basic which
was I wasn't born here my first
interaction with American kids when I
was like four and over then I don't talk
about it all ever was they forced me to
drink pee out of a Pepsi can you know
yeah and speak English like Outkast I
was four foot eleven my freshman year of
high school that was an underdog um you
know like I was a bad student and the
system told me I was [ __ ] um I hated
Kobe Bryant his whole career until the
last two years when he was washed up I
hated Tiger Woods when everybody loved
him he was dominating now I love him
when he's not winning I'm just underdog
driven the Yankees and Rangers I don't
give a [ __ ] about anymore because they
won like so I only keep the key teams
and care about the teams that are
climbing I'm just I'm in for the climb I
have a chip on my shoulder and I'm an
underdog driven and it drives the [ __ ]
out of me it's genuinely why I believe
my son has no prayer to beat me ever
because he'll be super privileged he's
gonna live on the Upper East Side
he has a home in Bridgehampton he
[ __ ] is gonna go to town school he's
gonna like he's gonna fly private to the
[ __ ] Super Bowl he's [ __ ]
finished you know kill him you know
yeah sure to be a social media influence
Rianna you have to have something to say
that people give a [ __ ] about so cool
like you basically said how do I get a
bunch of people to give a [ __ ] about me
and I think it starts with like I'll
give you I'll actually give you a really
good piece of ice it's probably the
thing I can probably answer the best
only your truth only your truth cuz it's
the only thing you got everything else
is like everybody else's only your truth
you know what that means you got to be
brave you got to go to those places you
don't want to go got it and then you got
to tell the world about it it's all you
got because it's not a hack it's not be
smart with hashtags it's not go JV with
another influencer it's at the end of
the day no matter how much works I can
[ __ ] give you love on my snapchat
story for the rest of the year if you
can't do anything with that love you're
not going to win and the only thing that
I've seen really really work that has
any longevity look you can have cute
little blue eyes and be nash grier for
two years right you can be like you can
like like every but like you know like
what I don't think people realize is
like there's only so much tits and ass
you can show on Instagram and look like
like like like to have true longevity
the only thing you've got is your truth
locations like this one
like hey
how do we think about moving here with
Stephen Ross and I said so Stephens
obviously our business partners the
biggest real estate developer in the
world he's building the biggest project
in New York we're growing and the
funniest part is the whole time I'm like
no way no way I'm not going [ __ ]
fancy I'm not paying that [ __ ] rent
no way no way no way
and then truth is I just really
negotiated hard core with them and price
kept coming down terms kept getting
better we kept growing there was only so
many floors available and I was just
like uh and so like the truth is it just
worked out that we became big enough to
afford it at the time that it became
available but I never aspired I'll be
very honest with you I've said it I mean
it I'm real worried that everybody here
has gotten too fancy because of it I'm
super scared man this is [ __ ] nice
like we have real serious people coming
through the last week and they're like
whoa I'm like [ __ ] like if this [ __ ]
[ __ ] fancy [ __ ] thinks this is whoa
we're deep [ __ ] I need it I genuinely
mean it now on the flip side
no nice it is like I'm so happy that do
you now nice it is that people get to
have flavored seltzer so that's really
just how worked out
now there's no romantic story of how we
got here it was just [ __ ] I was not
like oh I couldn't wait for Neiman
[ __ ] Marcus yeah there you're not
gonna sell five million dollar
apartments on my thesis
I'm Sondre so I'm talking to you after
so I'm gonna skip you to sneaky so like
right this second
what time is it yeah okay cool
we'll figure it out when you out okay
good
I wish we can go back to the good old
days we talking pursue other any apps No
evolution is evolution right like I know
you know like the good old days are not
as good as you think like that's just
old people talk like tell grandma sue to
shut the [ __ ] up you guys do you guys
you guys do do you guys remember do you
guys remember have you guys seen that
photo that everybody loves to point to I
don't know if you've seen this it's the
photo when the Pope came and everybody's
got a like the camera and there's that
one 90 year old woman and she's looking
and everybody wants to make her a star
for she really captured she didn't
capture [ __ ] she's 90 she already forgot
and if she took a photo she could have
enjoyed herself today but instead she
had no idea I'm being dead serious I
think that old woman lost and everybody
wants to make her a hero like no because
this is the way it is and like we we
have proven for much longer than our
grandparents have been around that we
evolved if a caveman was dug up right
now from [ __ ] 3,000 years ago plopped
right here be like what tough like like
like they thought like they told us the
telephone was bad do you know what did
you see this article I sent you guys you
might have some drugs I don't know if
are you on the team Gary Elias do they
put you on or now got it so the
Kaleidoscope you know what the biggest
problem in the world in 1816 was was
people walking around with a
kaleidoscope in real life and it ruined
us
no so no you couldn't even imagine I
loved debating with people that have
ideological like romances of how it was
like no you take the good with the bad
whatever makes you sad about the way we
are now there's eight billion good like
do you know that my generation and you
I'm still not that much older than you
like lost touch with high school friends
and never to be talked to again until
nine years later miraculously on
Facebook like there's so much good do
you know much more social you are I love
them people like you're not social
you're dramatically more social than
your parents were
it may happen different form so what
writing a letter is so much more noble
than texting somebody what the [ __ ] is a
matter of people like the girls that I
grew up in high school that had a phone
in their room and lay there all day and
watch Saved by the Bell and talk to the
phone for 14 hours a day that was so
much greater than what you're doing
that's just old people talk who are sad
its defense
that's a great question I think one that
found the best client for us to do the
best work I think one that was
open-minded but was grounded in truths
so not letting us get to like you need
to do the next thing but was open like
just open-minded in the same way I am
about around technology
I'm just open-minded about it like
everybody defaults to anything that's
change is bad let me just go back Holly
I'm sorry become still so pissed about
this question in a great way people we
you know like like I don't know if your
parents or grandparents or old people
that you know ever did this when you go
to a restaurant or if you do it and see
a couple sitting there and they're both
on the phone and like oh that's so sad I
don't think that's sad let me tell you
from an old person's perspective what I
say that same couple 15 years ago they
were sitting there and they just worked
in sitting across from each other not
saying a [ __ ] word their relationship
is broken the phone isn't the reason
technology is just exposing who you are
not changing you so the client
open-minded this
yes I'm obsessed with August yes
I just think August is the most
interesting [ __ ] month it's the month
when most people shut it down and I
think the best time to put it on is when
everybody else is it it's also the month
right before [ __ ] gets real from a
business standpoint September to
December like like that's prime time
that's when the culmination of
everything kind of hits and so I find it
fascinating that people like it's kind
of like if you're running a marathon and
like I'm the third away through you like
stop you got to start up again [ __ ] got
it so I really took advantage of August
my whole career but as you saw in that
video
there's the alternative for people like
me like next Wednesday I'm ghost until
the day after Labor Day and I'm pumped
about it I miss my family like I need
that three weeks you know Austin what's
yours out of college I I played a lot of
Madden football and I sold [ __ ] I mean
every day in Kyle it's funny my college
friend have been reminding me of [ __ ] I
forgot like I would go to the dollar
store buy [ __ ] and try to sell it on
eBay and I had very little downtime I
went home every single Friday think
about this
I went home every Friday to go work at
the liquor store and then come back
Sunday night it's just what I wanted you
know I was I just knew what I knew who I
was I knew what it was I knew what I
knew what was happening
patience when launching a new business
were like your brainchild on tonight if
you get support to get on so you start
moving early better to serve actively I
think I think it's so earlier to
Julian's quite like I think it's
important for you in the beginning of
your business if anybody wants to start
one only do the thing that you're best
at like so if you're just good at
selling like just sell don't worry about
your marketing if you're good at
marketing if you learn something here do
that what people do it's like you know
you'll have this experience one day
maybe like it's like what do you expect
from a three-year-old child like my
little guy Zander is about to turn for
next week like sometimes he'll do things
got an older sister so we forget were 40
and 35 like we forget he's [ __ ] 44
months old like what do you want from
him you know what I mean and I think a
lot of people try to do everything in
the beginning of a business your
business is a baby vaynermedia didn't
look like this seven years ago we're
making up [ __ ] in a conference room half
the size of that and like what do we do
like let's build website you know like
that so that's what I would do all right
let's go
your turn Mike how do you do that
Helen one more time I'm sorry how do you
mean so they I dream so big because my
mom allowed me to
and like and I will tell you that I will
that the single biggest reason I think I
have a public persona is because I feel
so damn guilty of how perfectly parented
I was and if I can give you guys even a
little bit of something your parents
might not give you then I'll accomplish
paying back what I think I was gifted
that's why Henley because my mom really
made me feel like I could but my mom did
really well was she praised me for my
good things but didn't allow eighth
place trophies meaning if I did if I
lost she wasn't like you won like the
all these [ __ ] stupid modern parents
like no no he lost like I'm in [ __ ]
oh my god I tell Lizzy I'm like so
petrified of the Upper East Side I'm
like you know if you lose you lose like
Xander
my little guy Xander he will not score a
basket on me and basketball for the next
15 years that's a hundred percent AJ I
wish she was here actually but I just
left I wish you guys could talk to him
AJ didn't score a basket on me until he
was like 15 a basket and so she did that
well but more importantly if I opened
the door I don't never forget this I
opened the door for a lady at McDonald's
when I was like nine you would have
literally thought that I [ __ ] won the
Nobel Peace Prize she she made that such
a big deal and I think that's what she
did well and so that's why I think I can
dream big because I just feel it you
know
you got it LA so um
during the last maybe six or six or
seven weeks or so whatever the [ __ ] it
is um I've been trying to work as hard
as I can to try to put myself in a
position to work here and then what
happened um I guess what my question is
is that I've been working so hard I'm
doing everything I can
people have been telling me we're doing
a good job but um I still just feel like
enough yet like I remember one time
there was an article put out that you
said that when you buy the Jets that's
going to be like your worst day ever
because you will finally have done what
you've been trying to do all this time
it's gonna suck um so I guess that's the
question you know what are we working
towards if we're never satisfied what we
got until we get it and then it's over
what do you mean oh if that's how you're
wired
you're just as lucky as I am anybody
who's lucky enough to love the process
more than the thing has [ __ ] won
because you spend a lot more [ __ ]
time on the process than the thing yes
[ __ ] yeah Peter like like and by the way
like I if you decide to apply apply
permanently cuz you said you want to get
a job here
I personally Emily make sure this
happens I'm personally gonna write you
the note that you got the job and it's
gonna say I'm sorry I'm sorry you got
the job Harris let's go
cool um my question is I thought I was
really competitive at first and then I
played you in basketball at bm7 and
realized I'm not competitive at all okay
and then I had to step up my game you
get more competitive with people that
around you or yes actually no one I'm so
proud of you for asking this question
actually I really do I'm surprised I'm
so excited by this I have a good piece
of advice actually start trimming your
friend group and start adding to your
friend group predicated on what you want
to be the answer is absolutely my man
like you absolutely I am stunned how
much more I am like my wife and how much
more she is like me even though we
started at very polar places it's just
true who you hang out with like there is
such a smart hack to like and it's
really the like that cliche thing like
you are like the byproduct when people
like oh that's real super real so maybe
this is a good year for you to like kind
of audit that first day back look around
maybe know a friend of a friend and if
you like what you see go explore it and
try to be around it because yeah man I
think that you got more competitive by
being around me and I can tell you right
now I know everybody on my team they're
different I'll tell you one thing that I
can tell you firm about d-roc
and Nate for sure I'll give you those
two examples they're a fuckload more
confident they were than they were when
they came into my life because my
confidence rubbed off on them straight
up Andres I worked every single weekend
of my college life at the liquor store
and then I watched a Jets game on Sunday
in the fall and then I took Amtrak back
to Boston and during January through May
I worked every weekend I mean I
literally spent seven weekends in four
years in college
seven seven so I just worked new
girlfriend's that's really it you oh I'm
so sorry
Andres you [ __ ] jerk so sorry I
didn't see you
good job yes
the good news is creatives is wide open
meaning you can go directly you can
apply to be a junior copywriter you know
the truth is I'm going to talk to
Babcock about that later this year
there's a tricky little thing with the
creative thing we're in a place where
we're in a place where there's a lot of
business advantages to hire somebody
who's done it for a year somewhere else
but I don't like that part and so I'm
trying to figure out what's right I
don't want to be romantic about my own
thing right I don't want to be
ideological my own way so the truth is I
don't know actually it's a great way to
like and this which is I this is one
thing I really don't have an answer for
because I definitely don't have the
answer that I want for people I don't
know but I can tell you that I
definitely want to try to figure out a
way that people could get that job
straight out of school because they do
it in every other place so I can't wait
I just need to know how Steve wants
creative to judge that person because I
need to understand it guys thanks for
your time
[Applause]